for the showdown between Game of Thrones season
1 and House of the Dragon season 1 we're going to
compare these two shows in five categories and
see which ones they exceed in it may be pretty
obvious to some people that Game of Thrones season
1 is better but how does it stack up against the
beginning of House of the dragon and how close
are they in terms of quality and how they started
their own shows so first let's dive into the
efficiency of setting up story elements fight
both Game of Thrones and House of the dragon have
to do a lot of setup since the world of Westeros
is massive and there are dozens of characters that
are integral to the plots these are introductory
Seasons so the biggest obstacle from a writing
standpoint is to educate the audience but not in a
boring manner this includes all the characters the
different houses political allegiances motivations
for the characters and geography so any show
taking on this task is extremely difficult
once you venture into the territory of too much
Exposition you'll quickly lose your audience to
boredom boom both got and hot tea don't fall
into these pitfalls and handle their setup
extremely well between the two shows I think Game
of Thrones takes on the bigger burden since there
are more characters and they have to deal with
more perspectives and subplots around the world
after the first couple of episodes it splinters
into net and King's Landing Tyran getting taken
to the veil Jon Snow at the Night's Watch and
Rob Stark and brand back in Winterfell it's
a lot harder to juggle multiple plot lines than
having a couple of main ones that follow a few key
characters you have to balance each episode and
make them feel satisfying despite only having a
very limited amount of time along with having just
enough time to build up each subplot to have a
good resolution by the finale as opposed to House
of the Dragon where each episode has one General
Arc that everyone goes through together and you
don't really have to worry about balancing a bunch
of different perspectives because from a writing
point of view you have to be very particular about
how much screen time each subplot will require
I wouldn't say that either of these methods of
Storytelling is better than the other but Game of
Thrones has to tell a more expansive story with
like five plot lines and that even gets more
numerous later on then there's also the factor
of more characters and by having more characters
that then introduces the need to set up new houses
and political allegiances in House of the Dragon
you really only need to know about the targaryens
the high Towers the strongs and the valerions
meanwhile in Game of Thrones season 1 the houses
that are integral to the story include the Starks
baratheons Lannisters targaryens house Aaron and
two other cultures that aren't houses but are
still relevant like the night Swatch and the
Dothraki got season 1 is naturally more ambitious
in terms of its scale and because of that I think
it deserves some extra points within this category
so now the question arises in that which show
executes its given introductory material better
and to me that's pretty much equal I think both
shows expertly make their setup intriguing and
they do it in slightly different ways for Game
of Thrones they do have more traditional form of
character introduction and there is expository
dialogue however they quickly hook you into the
show with an engrossing mystery and an insane
plot twist a bran getting pushed out of a window
along with the opening scene being the literal
definition of a hook where the first thing you
witness is the white walkers right away you're
given a taste of what's to come and the larger
conflict within the world so any Exposition you
may get bogged down by is instantly forgiven by
the story getting a major Catalyst that Sparks
the interest of the audience in the exposition
we do get within the first couple of episodes is
always interesting and as quickly and efficiently
done some examples include Ned Stark executing the
deserter who ran away which both pays off their
first scene and sets up the code of honor that
Ned lives by the archery scene remember quickly
learned the dynamic between most of the characters
through primarily actions and expressions like
these quick glances between Catelyn and Jon and
most of the dialogue is more personally driven
that has a lot of subtexts like Robert talking
about how much he loved lyanna and Tyrion talking
John for Tyrion he's not giving a monologue that
introduces himself but instead the advice he gives
and how he acts around Jon and others gives us a
perfect illustration as to who he is and we can
quickly put together that he's a black sheep of
the Lannisters for House of the Dragon it doesn't
really feel like we get formal introductions and
the writers don't hold our hands we get ushered
into this story and the writers don't make up any
mechanics to naturally introduce us to everyone
like how in Game of Thrones Robert Baratheon
Ventures down to Winterfell and each character
essentially introduces themselves and we have
someone like Arya being obsessed with different
characters shouting out something like this
could you please shut up House of the Dragon
starting point feels like an ordinary day and
we're witnessing these characters carry out their
normal business and through this in some minor
form of conflict introduction the characters
immediately take their shape by how they react
to it along with the fact that the writers
prioritizes select few main characters for the
audience to really get to know instead of trying
to give everyone a moment to shine before they
go off on their own Adventures like in Game of
Thrones there are multiple characters within the
first episode of hot tea that the writers don't
really bother to set up and that's perfectly fine
because the story isn't about them yet House of
the Dragon may not have a crazy turning point in
the story like a major betrayal to distract people
from a lot of developments and the story focuses
more on character-related drama that's what the
first season of House of the Dragon is focused
on at the end of the day so to say whether or not
Game of Thrones or House of the Dragon is better
at introducing story elements I think it's about
even however I'd give the slight Edge to Game of
Thrones for having to take on a bigger load in
setting up material just barely because of this
Game of Thrones wins in this category since we
talked a little bit about the story within the
first couple of episodes let's go into the general
plot of these two seasons and see which one has
the better story as discussed prior House of
the Dragon is more concentrated on building
characters and their stories as opposed to the
plot constantly going crazy then for Thrones it
does put a lot of focus on characters but the
story does go on a wild ride for the first four
seasons the plot is like lightning in a bottle
and is more than Perfection it's always going down
surprising directions it's very unpredictable and
every plot twist drastically changes the landscape
to the point that the show keeps evolving House of
the Dragon is more straightforward in comparison
which is obviously not a bad thing but when
compared to Game of Thrones it's kind of rough
because in terms of plot twists that drastically
changed the story we have the death of Sir Harwin
the death of luceris and technically the fake
out death of Sir Leonard all of these events
change the story to a big degree and there are
other shocking moments like the death of vaman's
but that doesn't have as big of an impact as he
may think he dies and the story doesn't change
that much as a result and that's not to say it's
a bad moment and it was great when looking at Game
of Thrones season 1 we have bran getting pushed
out of a window Catelyn kidnapping Tyrion Jaime
attacking Ned Ned finding out the truth about
Cersei and Jaime Bobby Beacon and killed Ned
getting betrayed his death viserys's death Khal
drogo's death the season is flat out stacked and
there are even more than the ones I listed but I
physically can't keep going because I'm running
out of breath the twists are so massive and even
check up the storytelling medium like killing the
main character it's just staggering how many plot
twists George R Martin was able to cram into this
season and it's even crazier how he's able to
keep this up over the next three seasons now the
reason why I'm focusing so much on plot to us is
that both Game of Thrones and House of the Dragon
perfect every other story element to the the point
that I have to find some major differences to set
them apart another one of those differences in
favor of House of the Dragon is that I think the
depth of character work is a bit deeper I don't
think this Gap is as big in relation to the plot
twist Gap but there are certain character arcs
like viserys that hits an emotional depth that
got season 1 doesn't get to it has the death of
Ned Stark and that was very shattering but that's
more of a shocking twist rather than character
building the death of visceros isn't necessarily
the sad part and instead it's a slow deterioration
of his body and overall image and how that impacts
his relationships seeing loved ones wither away
is extremely depressing because it's basically
a death that lasts a long duration instead of
lasting one quick moment with so much of that
agonizing pain slowly building up over time so
does the amount of sympathy that surrounds them
viserys's Journey hits this narrative aspect to
a perfect tee along with the makeup Department
applying an astonishing amount of detail to his
visual Decay from the color of his skin slowly
changing his hair starting to thin his skin and
body parts succumbing to rot the way he walks
breathes and acts are also detailed to the point
that it's one of the best performances with an
all of Game of Thrones then through all of this
tragedy we have a light at the end of the tunnel
and it's the absolute cherry on top and that's
the last supper words can't describe the amount
of wholesome and sweet energy that radiate from
the scene now I should be saving all this for
the characters category later on but I think
it's important to bring up the fact that house
of the Dragon has some outstanding story focused
character developments if hot tea had this aspect
along with some more game-changing plot twists
then I think it could match the first season
of Game of Thrones however there is one more
narrative aspect of House of the dragon that
brings it down a bit and that's the time jumps and
it's not all of them doing time jumps is generally
fine within storytelling but when you are
intentionally leaving out development in between
that time that is crucial for certain story
arcs then you run into issues the whole point
of a time Jump is to skip over over a duration
of time that doesn't have much plot progression
in House of the Dragon it feels like the craters
are more using time jumps because HBO refuses to
make more than 10 episodes for a season because
of this there are consequences like plot threads
not continuing and leaving the audience confused
or leaving out key character developments this in
turn tarnishes the payoff from these plot lines
and is the main reason why I think episode 6 is
the worst of the season this is a minor issue that
primarily impacts one episode and a couple others
but we're comparing this to the Masterpiece that
is Game of Thrones season one and there I think
the story is just way more captivating than it is
in Hot D it's a perfect storm of a murder mystery
entangled in a web of political conspiracies
and this is just one of the plots of the first
season John Danny and Tyrion all have fun story
arcs in the season and all these together along
with the insane number of twists make the general
plot better than House of the Dragon let's take a
break from talking about narrative elements and
compare the production quality between these two
Seasons right away it may be a little unfair
because House of the dragon has a budget of
about 20 million dollars per episode while Game
of Thrones had about 6 million dollars per episode
in season one but I'm not going to hold that
against Game of Thrones too much and we'll try
to take into account that they're playing at a
disadvantage if anything though 6 million per
episode in 2011 was still a big budget the first
production aspect that I think has the biggest
difference is the cinematography House of the
Dragon looks much more cinematic than Game of
Thrones shots have moodier lighting and seem more
planned in execution there's a sharp and warm
color gray that seems like it has more contrast
and the black levels are a bit lower the aspect
ratio is different and has black bars instead of
the full screen presentation and lastly it feels
like there are more Dynamic camera moves whether
that be rack focuses or Dolly shots and there
are a lot more shots that incorporate a shallow
Focus or at least submerges you into the acting
in the first season of Game of Thrones visually
only a few scenes stand out to me which are the
execution of Ned Stark and how we were put into
the headspace of Ned through close-ups along with
the audio design helping with that tearing in
the sky cell which is uplifted by the VFX and
then Varys and Littlefinger talking in the Great
Hall which really doesn't have anything special
shot-wise and is mainly carried by the set piece
and how Grand it is most of these iconic visuals
tend to have another aspect that carries them
while in House of the Dragon ordinary dialogue
scenes look gorgeous I keep going back to this
scene in episode 2 where Allison consoles ranera
by candlelight the warm light that hugs their
faces as they pour out emotions to one another
as such a precious visual delight and this isn't
just one occurrence because House of the dragon
has a big collection of beautiful looking dialogue
scenes in almost every scene there's at least one
shot that sticks with me whether it be this dollar
shot on the beach this unnecessarily artsy shot
that spins around a cup while it's being filled
Allison having her silhouette highlighted by the
golden rays of the sunlight the this close-up of
viserys's rotting finger or literally any shot
from the Dragonstone confrontation because
the atmosphere is so tense with the fog and
the sunset lighting and hey guess what all
these examples were pulled from just half of
one episode and I think that alone highlights the
fact of how consistently great the cinematography
is in this show Game of Thrones in comparison
isn't as impressive because it feels a lot more
naturalistic it doesn't feel like there's a
cinematic color grade to it and most of the
footage is generally shot with a deeper Focus
there's even a big visual difference if you go
later into the show where there's more dramatic
lighting and everything else I mentioned while
talking about House of the Dragon is present for
season 1 there really isn't anything wrong with
this style and it gets the job done it's just
since we're comparing the style to something
that's more cinematic I think the Cinematic option
will be better looking at the VFX of season 1 I
think it still holds up extremely well primarily
because it's used to properly execute the skill of
the World by showing off its fictional locations
like the wall and numerous exotic kingdoms season
1 is still able to pass as high quality television
for today's standards and even though they don't
have massive dragons walking around I think the
VFX is still really good the sets as well are
still very impressive and the first time you walk
into the throne room you are always Blown Away by
how massive it is proportionally compared to
House of the Dragon since they have different
budgets I think Game of Thrones is pretty similar
in terms of VFX and production design because on
a technicality House of the Dragon will always
be better in these aspects because of the higher
budget but I think it's very commendable That
Game of Thrones is able to give them a run for
their money there's also another small issue with
got smaller budget in the first season and that's
the fact that they weren't able to execute the
battles from a spectacle and action standpoint
it would have been really cool to see them but
I think from a narrative standpoint David and
Dan were still able to make it work if anything I
think this again goes to show how Rock Solid the
story is in season one however this round for
production quality goes to House of the Dragon
one aspect between these two shows that I've been
keeping track of is the dialogue because House of
the Dragon actually has some really well written
dialogue given that it doesn't have much in the
source material the way people speak feels
accurate to the period and doesn't feel out
of place there are enough quotable lines that
will keep anyone satisfied and each character
is expressed perfectly for the dialogue they are
given especially Damon Targaryen she could have
her out to now stuffed in her father's mouth along
with his withered cop let's end this Mama's far
House of the Dragon in comparison to most shows
blows them away but when it comes to Game of
Thrones I think this is the golden standard for
outstanding dialogue and almost every scene there
will be a standout line that will immediately
imprint on you just now if I tell you to think
about your favorite line in season 1 of Game of
Thrones you'll probably immediately think of Love
is the death of Duty a lion doesn't concern
himself with the opinions of the sheep when
you play the game of thrones you win or you die
or literally anything that comes out of tyrion's
mouth my brother has a sword and I have my mind
and the mind needs books like a sword needs a
whetstone since it's been like a month since the
end of House of the Dragon there aren't as many
lines that have stuck with me in comparison to
Game of Thrones if you ask the same question to
recount some of the best lines from Hot D you'd
probably be able to think of a few but not as
many as I'd expect for got that's not to say that
the iconic lions and House of the Dragon are worse
in particular I just think that George R Martin
outclassed the writers and his usage of literary
devices were amazing especially with Tyrion the
man just oozes so much wisdom and the character
on his own is a mouthpiece for some of the best
dialogue in the show without Tyrion then maybe
House of the Dragon would have a slim chance but
I think Tyrion is like the sarbarrassing selmia
fighting but for dialogue every scene he is in
his dialogue puts you into a trance that makes
you immediately fall in love with his character
essentially A Perfect combo for his personality
and the writing surrounding him that masterfully
brings him to life the only character that comes
close and has the dragon in terms of charming
Charisma is Damon and he doesn't really have
many iconic lines unfortunately any seemingly
good dialogue that surrounds his character is
more carried by the great acting from Matt Smith
meanwhile in Game of Thrones I'm always impressed
by the intelligent and meaningful lines that are
always jumping from the script I am putting a lot
of emphasis on iconic lines and that's because
I think both shows nail all other aspects for
dialogue expertly to the point that I essentially
have to do an to arms race for memorable lines and
when it comes to that race Game of Thrones wins so
even though Geo team wins in that aspect I think
hot diesel has great dialogue that is able to sit
next to Game of Thrones without anyone feeling
like there's a massive disparity in quality for
the last category I wanted to save what I would
think would be the most interesting one and that's
the characters I'd also classify this category as
being the most subjective because this category
will be skewed more by which characters you are
drawn to the most to lay out some facts right away
Game of Thrones has more characters than House of
the dragon and not just more Side characters
but main characters too now I wouldn't say
that having more is better because that means
you have to divide your time much more across
the show instead of being able to focus on the
select few main characters however I don't think
any of the main characters are heard as a result
of this in Game of Thrones they just may not hit
the absolute highs that visares Arc was able to
get to now you can argue that Ned Stark would
rival that but I think the plot point of his death
makes his character naturally more iconic than the
character himself because when looking at Ned he
doesn't have as deep and expansive of an arc as
viserys does he's a man of Honor who chooses
to go down the rabbit hole of the mystery of
Don Aaron's death and along the way he meets his
demise the one thing that actually changed about
his character was in the dungeons before his
execution he learns to drop his immense Pride
surrounding his honor and chooses to try to
save his daughters in an act that destroys
what defines him that's obviously great but
in comparison to viserys there's a lot more
going on internally and even externally a king
who tries his hardest to continue the Glorious
terrain of King jaharis but is constantly making
mistakes that worsens the world around him these
mistakes Define viserys because he wants to make
everyone happy to the point that he loses sight of
the ramifications of his actions like preemptively
making renira his Heir allowing the stepsons to
become a festering issue choosing to be ignorant
towards or near a having bastards and allowing
the Divide between the greens and the blacks to
grow viserys is constantly changing his mind and
seeing him reflect on his mistakes creates solid
moments of character developments that layer of
confidence in being King melts away and we see
this frail man who like anyone else regularly
has regrets and Sorrows our image of his search
changes immensely from episode to episode and in
most of them we tend to learn something integral
tied to the essence of his character I can go on
for a while about viserys and I did go on for a
bit in the general plot section but to say the
least I think he's one of the most captivating
leads between the two shows the rest of the
main characters in House of the Dragon I don't
think are able to get to the peak that viserys
was able to get to like runira had an intense
journey through adolescence and her adulthood
was even more hectic but I'd argue that Daenerys
had just as good of an arc for season one seeing
her go from a fully suppressed and scared child
to an independent woman who builds the confidence
to stand up to the oppressive men around her and
become a leader was a great journey it may not go
as in depth as renera emotionally since she had
more screen time however I think Game of Thrones
is able to utilize that smaller amount of screen
time for each of its main characters really well
like Tyrion John Danny Ned Cersei Jaime Arya
and many more feel just flesh out enough for
the audience to love them and it doesn't feel like
anything is missing for us to understand what they
are going through also since the budget for the
show is smaller that means that most scenes tend
to be dialogue scenes so we actually have more
time within the show for character building than
we did in House of the Dragon since there isn't
as much action I know I said that quantity of
characters within Game of Thrones doesn't make
it better than hot D but I think they were able
to hit that hard goal of quantity and quality
while House of the dragon has a smaller quantity
but just as much quality and if not a bit more
I love Damon Allison Otto Rainier and viserys
but it essentially stops there for the S tier
characters also since Game of Thrones naturally
has more subplots they are able to introduce more
Side characters without it feeling overwhelming
because if you have the same amount of characters
in Game of Thrones for just two main plot lines
like in House of the Dragon then it will become
very crowded for this this category House of the
Dragon is able to give Game of Thrones a run for
its money but ultimately it's almost impossible to
beat the perfect Ensemble of characters for Game
of Thrones if they were able to give the rest of
the main characters in hotty and equally orgasmic
character Arc as viserys had then maybe it would
be better than Game of Thrones season 1. even
though House of the Dragon lost in four of the
five categories it came very close to matching the
quality that his season 1 of Game of Thrones given
that the story is supposed to get even crazier in
season 2 of House of the Dragon then I won't be
surprised if it's able to exceed the greatness
of season 2 of got thank you for watching and
let me know in the comments if you want me
to do any more of these versus Style videos
foreign